all right thank you it's a new year and
you know what that means it means a
whole new roster of movies look forward
to in 2023. I can no Wade and Netflix
just dropped a jam-packed teaser for its
must watch films arriving this year with
sequels to fan favorites and
introductions to new characters lots and
lots and lots to watch so save the dates
there's no shortage of star power with
new films featuring our favorites like
Julia Roberts Marshall Ali Idris Elba
Adam Sandler Jennifer Anderson Millie
Bobby Brown and many many more and keep
an eye out for what appears to be a
steamy kiss between Nicole Kidman and
Zac Efron in a family affair take a look
I'm coming for you
[Music]
all right guys we got work to do
[Music]
so do you hang out in the hood all the
time or do you just come up here for our
food and women where's our waiter
[Music]
you and I tell each other everything
right always
this is my case I've got to make this
right
your reputations proceed you there you
go thank you that's nice to hear not in
a positive way I'm afraid oh not
okay okay
and whatever I need to be to keep her
safe
how do you feel [ __ ] coming over time
they have no idea what they're capable
of but life is full of surprises
what are we left about
I got it
for me anyway
I can take you out of here
something is happening and I don't trust
them what what does she know there's a
lot there's a lot going on
the moment it started you're like oh
Eddie Murphy
there's so many stories it's amazing
what we can watch now in streaming
services like that are just going to be
epic right yes I'm looking forward to
murder mystery part two because my kids
are obsessed with Adam Sandler Adam
Sandler has been going on a tear with
these Netflix guys he's been good too
yeah right like we're gonna miss it was
a lot of fun
um Leo is another one that he is that
he's doing that one with the the lizard
yeah that's awesome uh I am really
looking forward to Loser Fallen son yeah
okay we were just hooked on Luther it
was our favorite show and I didn't
realize how much I've been missing until
I saw that five seconds in that case I
was like oh loses coming back yeah and
this is how you do teasers like we're
both so excited and pumped for every
movie that's coming up we gotta wait for
the whole year for all of it to come
well that's why you said you put it in
your calendar and you go but I'm a
Binger like I like to watch like
so you'll wait until December 31st 2023
and then binge all the movies
no no I don't